hey sam how are you hi morgan good to
see you
and i see you too okay first most
important question i saw that you were
tweeting celine dion recently so i have
to ask
were you able to get her a sam hugh and
t-shirt
i i haven't got her one yet but
obviously we have this movie together
which is coming out next year hopefully
so when
maybe when the world opens up and we can
uh we can actually celebrate and go to
premiere
i'll make sure i give her one definitely
you have to we all want to see this um
now as you're saying you just wrapped
you just wrapped on this new film with
priyanka chopra and celine diana what
was it like working with celine on her
feature film acting debut
yeah she's such an icon isn't she and i
think i believe
she's also like doing the music for it
as well and um
for me it's such a fun little movie it's
it's a really nice
romantic comedy and priyanka chopra is
such a
classy lady i really enjoyed working
with her she's she's fantastic
that's amazing all right so from a
romantic comedy to this film this film
is action-packed you know on a scale of
one to ten how intense is the training
for this i mean there's just so many
weapons
yeah yeah there is you know it's it is
it's a real roller coaster
uh action movie thriller as well um yeah
and there was
there was on a scale i guess probably a
ten you know i did a lot of work with uh
the special forces um working in the
military working with like uh
tactical movement working with weapons
um and then also you know working with
andy mcnabb himself who wrote the book
and his
basically this character is based on him
um was
was fascinating to learn sort of all the
military side
well that's awesome um it was really fun
watching you and ruby rose go toe to toe
in this film you know there's chemistry
even though you guys are against each
other in this uh what was it like
working with her
yeah ruby is brilliant and obviously
she's had so much
experience herself in action um so we
knew you know by the end of the movie we
really wanted to go for it and
um we wanted that final fight sequence
to be you know really gritty really
visceral
um lethal you know these two train
killers
uh really trying to stop the other so um
we did a lot of that
ourselves you know we we trained really
hard for the fight and um
yeah she's brilliant that's awesome okay
now you don't have to ask i'm just a fan
of outlander is there any way that you
can get her a cameo on that show
oh yeah i had thought of that i'm not
sure she would love being in the cold
um you know we were pretty cold and
budapest when we were shooting there but
yeah i'm sure we could get her a cameo
if she wants it um she's busy though
she's doing lots of great stuff
yeah she definitely is um you know aside
from all the training all the action
work in this
you basically had to play a character
that has to turn off his emotions and
kind of wrangle with that so what was
that like for you as an actor getting
into that kind of head space
yeah this this is really the reason why
i wanted to do this movie it's obviously
a fascinating character study of andy
mcnabb himself and he is
you know a good psychopath and i think
it's hard to get your head around
someone that has no emotions right but
um
uh and i guess the really interesting
plot twist to this one is that he he
discovers he's a good psychopath but
then also has an emotion at the end of
the movie so
um it just is a really fascinating
character study and was
was probably the thing i spent the most
time on with andy himself talking about
that
and and the repercussions of what it
means to be a psychopath
i love that you know you put so much
work into a film like this so to finally
see it fully through like do you feel
pretty proud of this film
oh i'm so proud it's it's been a long
time you know we shot this
um almost you know two years ago now and
it's just been delayed
due to you know what's going on in the
world but also you know there's so much
work in the background you know doing
prep and then also afterwards but i
think everyone should be very proud of
it it's it's a
it's a really fun movie well
congratulations on the film it's really
really nice getting to talk to you
thanks so much oh you too
thanks so much